it's not actually a free choice about
whether or not you verify yourself
[Music]
a legal perspective
you know with with anonymity is there
that thing that there are things you
wouldn't do in public life not only
because you know they would contravene
good manners and the way we all behave
with each other but also in real life we
count them as hate speech or you'd count
them as
um you know actually going breaking laws
and the moment you do it anonymously
online it's fine nobody nobody's calling
it out you can't be caught up called out
well you can't obviously you can be
called out and the platforms you know do
close down I mean they're getting much
much better
closing down accountable for it but
you're right they can't hold you
accountable but the police can
investigate but you know using vpns or
whatever you can it's quite it's quite
easy to cloak uh uh cloak your identity
and I mean I've I've come across cases
where you know quite sophisticated
abusers set up
um attack sites where where that they
they completely impossible to find out
who they are and and you can actually
cause a hell of a lot of damage if you
do it carefully and subtly and they've
done that and you know there is no
remedy
no way of holding yourself yeah just I
mean
on the example so 4chan for instance I I
from the perspective of my campaign I'm
a bit less concerned about something
like 4chan because it seems to me you
know there are victims and volunteers
those are people who they know what
they're getting into I'm more concerned
about the likes of Facebook Twitter that
those that are really our sort of
virtual Public Square the places that
people are being driven out of because
uh because of the abuse they get and it
seems unreasonable so I think we should
have a higher level of protection and
that's that's what the Online safety
build is trying to do is to get you know
give us a high level protection for the
for the major sites that we almost need
to be on these days and the other
distinction is between we're talking
about legal but harmful yeah so uh some
of the stuff we're talking about hate
speech and that that is a crime so that
of course gets treated in a different
way what we're talking about more is
bullying harassment disinformation the
stuff that we're never going to
criminalize but we're never left need to
try to give us the tools you mentioned
friction our proposal introduces
friction that's what it does
on the verification
before you you do and Stephen could you
just set out exactly how this
verification model would work so that
people understand if if it comes into
action how their lives would change how
would their their use of the internet
change yeah I should say as a starting
point we're very concerned we didn't
want verification to be on another huge
Trove of data for the large platforms
that they can use to to monetize Us and
Target us with advertising so there are
some very good third-party verification
Solutions out there and the for instance
one company called oneid they rely on
the data you've already given to your
bank in the UK 98 of us have have online
banking or access to it we've already
verified ourselves to them so we're not
looking for us all to have to again
upload our passport or our driving
license and give more data to the
platforms there are secure ways that you
having done it once you can then use
the way you verified yourself to that
third party provider you can then use
that to open your online account or your
social media account
s though I mean all the financial
benefits for them surprisingly not no no
talk us through not so through how the
model at the moment favors them like how
they're profiting from anonymity well I
they profit a number of ways obviously
they profit from anonymity because uh
abuse toxic discussion drives engagement
uh keeps people on the site longer
that's one way the other course the fact
that so many of the accounts out there
are fake and you see I mean Elon Musk is
concerned that Twitter might have more
than five percent fake accounts we think
the figures somewhere between 15 and 30
percent people say it's that's true of
Facebook as well but they are still
selling those fake eyeballs to
advertisers so
and we don't know because we can't get
access to the data I mean one of the
things that the bill and other
legislation wants to do is make these
platforms at least give access to the
data to researchers so that we can form
a truer picture of what's really going
on but I think there are so many ways
after all
they could make these changes now if
they cared about the user experience as
much as they do say they do if they
compared care about us as Citizens as
much as they say they do they could
introduce a lot of changes that would
improve our lives online
Victoria I mean I mean to see that
that unacceptable so yeah on kind of
verification specifically um
I wanted to know your perspective with
the critique of verification that it
risks potentially giving users a false
sense of security in the unless
platforms also have real name policies
where you like you have proven to a
platform that the name you are using on
a website is exactly the same as the
name that you've verified yourself at
it's like unless platforms use those
which on the whole they've tried to
introduce they don't work they again
it's like trans people who change their
name celebrities who want to have a
private account in a different name
teachers who want to hide who they are
like there are too many like groups who
really legitimately just shouldn't be
using their real names or whatever a
real name is like so unless it goes hand
in hand with real name systems doesn't
it risk providing users a full sense of
security that oh this person verified
themselves but like we don't actually
know if the name that they verified to
the platform is the name that they're
showing us that the pictures that
they're showing the platform is the
pictures that they're showing us and the
verification is just another thing that
will like it will also be abused I think
that that's a fair concern I mean I
ideally I'd like to see a Cascade where
right at the top we verified not only
your name but your location also that
we've verified any claim you make about
yourself if I look on Twitter the number
of people who claim to be x-forces I
mean how big was our army
all these ex nurses all these ex-vets I
mean so I would like to but I could also
Imagine at a lower tier of protection we
said well I just need to know you're a
real person I don't need to know who you
are I don't need to know the claims you
make about your Zaza true but at the top
yes we would certainly say
real name as an option again we're just
talking about my right to say I want to
screen out very I have a Cascade of risk
levels and I want to set my tolerance
for risk in terms of who I'm willing to
deal with so this would be a system
where users could decide that you don't
just don't want to engage with anyone
who hasn't been fully verified yeah you
can't be sure is a real person and you
could turn it on or off so you might
have put something out that you know is
going to get a bit of a backlash you
think well I'll dial it down for a few
weeks until that passes and then I'll
every time you leave one of these talks
exactly yeah nobody isn't verified can
can message you with that
is there a risk that you kind of create
like a kind of two-tier of internet use
this because
it's not actually a free choice about
whether or not you verify yourself right
because the assumption is that if you
haven't like like good people are going
to verify themselves therefore if you
haven't verified yourself like there's
probably something dodgy going on and
like even if you have concerns about
like where your data is going whether or
not that's justified in the way that the
system set up if you just have an issue
with the principle about aren't you
actually going to be kind of isn't there
a coercion happening there into
verifying yourself everything has a risk
of unintended consequences one of the
accounts that I like and follow is
called the secret Barrister and the clue
is in the name incredibly popular house
huge reach yeah
um he where do you stand on this system
of verification
I think the problem is that
the people like Stephen who are
concerned about these issues and perhaps
many people in the audience would take
advantage of the system but it requires
effort and you know 80 percent of people
aren't going to do it uh and so you you
get a small number of clean very five
people communicating with each other and
then you get the rest of the world uh uh
spewing out hate speech disinformation
and so on as before so the the you know
anything that requires people to to
think to engage to take positive steps
is going to have a massive Fallout rate
inevitably so actually we do we did
polling with yougov and compassion in
politics did polling through opinion and
they found that 80 of people will do it
people said said they would do it I'll
try a different thing original
preference yeah and who I mean do you
think the financial incentives for big
tech companies are just so high that
it's almost impossible now to to reverse
the situation to end anonymity which
which you'd like to see oh the the
financial incentives for I mean I mean I
agree with everything that Stephen said
I mean there's no doubt that anonymity
is financially beneficial to the big
tech companies but the big tech
companies do what they told I mean it's
that they they can tweak their system in
any any way they want I mean I I always
tell people the story I once had a case
against Google where my client was being
subject to all kinds of vile abuse and
and Google effectively said they could
do nothing about it technically
impossible they said we said you know
okay we sued them
case went on for six months
the week before the trial they said
actually you know not only is it
technically possible but actually it
won't cost us anything
so so you know they were able to do now
if you said to the tech companies you
have to do this otherwise you can't
operate in the UK they would do it
so yes it's not in their financial
interest but in in the end it's it's
more in their financial interest to to
do it than to not operate in the UK at
all
Stephen is there a danger you know
you've looked at this a lot but is there
a danger that if you do Force these big
tech companies to adopt this if you do
end anonymity as much as you can online
that you just force more and more people
into effectively the dark web into the
less regulated versions of of tech
platforms
obviously I'm in our our proposal won't
Force anyone to do anything because
we're again we're focusing on rights so
we're simply saying uh yes everyone will
still have the right to be anonymous and
they'll have the right to exercise their
free speech anonymously however we are
going to balance that so they all have
their Free Speech but I'm going to have
a right not to be shouted at so we won't
be driving anybody anywhere I do agree
with you on sort the financial
incentives for the platforms it is a
question though equally
um the UK is such a big digital Market
that it's going to be very hard and
we've you know how many times we heard
companies and platforms say well if you
change the rules the way we don't like
we're going to leave I mean other than
the with the example of China that
doesn't really happen there is another
constituency though that also doesn't
want change the likes of the status quo
and that's our press
because they in the Online safety
Builder have argued so far for a carve
out so that these rules shouldn't apply
to them or to their websites from which
increasingly they make a great deal of
their money so I mean just just explain
that to the audience why the Press would
want slightly different rules well the
press always want different rules yes
you know that's the journalist they can
vouch for that exactly
um they what's their real case I suppose
they again say it's free speech they say
uh we as journalists ought to be able to
to you know without fear or favor
um but they extend that to their
websites and of course that wouldn't be
such a problem if we had effective press
regulation I mean most other Industries
generally if they can persuade the
government to back off because they have
you know effective self-regulation we
don't in the case of the press so it is
a worry but this is you know this huge
pushback I should say from MPS from all
parties on this and there's very every
opportunity for you all to add your
voices if you're also concerned that we
shouldn't allow the press to behave at
carry on behaving in this way online and
on their comments pages
um I mean in a way anonymity is one of
those issues where you won't have the
same problem with the Press because I've
never met a journalist who doesn't want
to buy a line well and I'm sorry the
trouble is not just it's the comment
section yes so so the bizarre thing is
is is that the comment sections are
going to be entirely unregulated so so
as people have pointed out if I have a
Twitter account which I don't uh uh with
five followers I'm subject to ofcom the
Daily Mail with 60 million uh viewers is
is not regulated at all in relation to
its comment and the other thing is sorry
to God about this but the other thing is
that the way that the government have
defined the Press I can just set up
something called the newspaper and I can
publish anything I like and it's
unregulated
which is terrifying
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas